the Joe Rogan experience blick the idea
that a guy actually had a [ __ ] island
that's where he Gervase was joking about
last night I said of course it was no
but I did see the one clip that somebody
put on the internet about him saying
don't virtue signal just come on here
and get a little prize go [ __ ] off
because nobody cares about your opinion
I was like thank you thank you Ricky
thank you thank God that guy swings he's
out there swinging from the hip
chin up doesn't give a [ __ ] telling it
like it is I love it he went after I
love this kind of Tim Cook's it he went
after Apple then he said if Isis opened
up a studio y'all be sending your
resumes that what he said something more
yeah you'd all be like yes streaming
service she'll be contacting your agents
or something yeah that's what he said
like [ __ ] man
good for him so those are all
pre-written right because they had to
have this cuts ready to go I don't know
man he's so badass he might be able to
do whatever the [ __ ] he wants you know
he's Ricky Gervais he's got he's got the
ability to probably say oh I'll do it
I'll do it this way and only this way
and they're like okay Ricky we love you
we love you I we know you wouldn't do
anything to jeopardize our amazing
organization and we all love working
with you here at the Golden Gloves and
it's fun I mean you stir people up but
everybody knows you're a good guy he
goes hit somewhat genocide talk okay
Apple must have been so pissed we're
just getting away with use all that
slave labor and nobody even noticed
that's I mean it's another thing like
this murder right it's like that's just
how everything was done that's just how
everything was done this that's how they
whacked everybody and that was how you
got things built cheap the slave labor
but nobody knew nobody really understood
until you saw things like Foxconn you
like wait wait this is a good setup you
guys are working 16 hours a day you
sleep in the building this is a good
place this is good the stories I hear
Amazon workers like running around and
peeing themselves oh yeah yeah they have
some crazy countdown thing that goes
when they get an order and they have to
run to go get it probably a fun job if
you're into losing weight put on some
ankle weights oh [ __ ] maybe
weight vests and just run around that
thing you'd get a [ __ ] vicious
workout that's making lemonade out of
lemons right everything's a workout you
work it as a waiter at Applebee's and
that's it that's right think about it
man just with heavy weights around your
waist then no one would notice you could
have a good workout while you're working
the Apple thing that that had to sting
well he was standing right sitting right
there too and I show him right before he
starts saying it but he didn't throw any
ham and say what exactly something about
using sweats sweatshops and stuff like
that right in front of them but I mean
Foxconn is it's a sweatshop but it's
done like it's probably like the best
version of a sweatshop you know like you
know it's uh it's a real company and
it's its best version of a sweatshop
Silurian a Foxconn works in the United
States now right do they yeah I think
they actually have or they're about to
have companies here in the United States
I remember there was this is something
that Trump had talked about right yeah
on top of the annual Gervase ended his
monologue by telling the nominees so if
you do win here in award tonight
don't use it as a political platform to
make a political speech you're in no
position to lecture the public about
anything you know nothing about the real
world most of you spent less time in
school than Greta Thornburg so if you
win come up accept your little award
thank your agent and your God and [ __ ]
off okay the swear was beeped out by NBC
he also was was also beat for his use of
profanity and two other jokes one where
he called cats James Corden of fat [ __ ]
and another where he discussed the same
films Judi Dench licking her ass Wow the
comedian however also peppered the
monologue with references to me too in
contemporary issues you started off by
noting that was his fifth time hosting
and therefore he didn't care what flak
he would take then he punched in with a
nod to last year's college admissions
scandal I came here in a limo tonight
and the license plate
is made by Felicity Huffman good for him
he's a real comic cousin have the Apple
quote he's a real comic that's that's a
look there write down let's go down a
little I said a little lower than that
it's a TV Apple yeah while discussing
the edition of Apple TV plus to the room
Gervase noted the irony of a meet to
theme show like the morning show being
made by a company runs flesh shops in
China you say your walk but if Isis
started streaming service you'd call
your agent we're gonna get this right
folks
I really believe this good friend this
is what we're talking about earlier
about that everything being bad I don't
think it is I think it I think it's just
a lot of noise there's a lot of noise a
lot of people yelling it's swinging back
around already
it's swinging back around brush human
yeah you know we have weird things where
everything's change it's all changed now
everything's changed
okay relax we're okay we're gonna be all
right the world's [ __ ] we're [ __ ]
it's all it's all ending
[Applause]